(audience cheering)
(dramatic music)
- Good evening Inbound,
how are you?
(audience cheering)
I'm super excited
to be here, so excited.
Can we hear it one
more time for that?
That was fucking remarkable.
(audience cheering)
Good shit.
(breathes deeply)
I'm really excited about
tonight, it's a very special day
in our amazing
country and for me
it's especially special because
I wasn't born in the US.
I was born in the Soviet Union.
I came here as a little boy.
Both my grandfathers spent
substantial time in jail
just because they were Jewish.
And I know that
there's a lot of tension
and different beliefs about
what should happen tonight.
But the fact that
we're even able to vote
and to be in this
amazing country
is something that we have
lost perspective for.
(audience applauding)
And I'm very
thankful to be here tonight.
And to me it's super interesting
because I want to talk
about the journey
of an entrepreneur
and by hands, how many people
here are entrepreneurs?
Raise your hands.
Very nice.
And how many people here
work within organizations
that are entrepreneurial
within them?
Raise your hands.
Very nice.
If we can keep these lights
on that would be huge for me
if you don't mind.
So, for me, I think
the opening statement
is going to be this:
if you are sitting in this
room tonight and you believe
that whether Donald or
Hillary wins impacts you
you're a motherfucking loser.
- [Audience Member] Amen!
(slight applause)
And I want to explain this.
We're so lucky to be here
in this playing ground
where the impact of the
president only has so much
impact on you because the
reality is we're dramatically
and I mean dramatically
more in control of our lives
than the media
pounds down our throats.
And so I hope if
anything, if anything
whether you're 16 or 97
and you leave here tonight
you understand how
unbelievable our opportunity is
to play in this ecosystem.
What I want to talk about
tonight is a couple of things.
One, we're living
though the greatest era
of communication change that
we've lived through since
the printing press, and
regardless of what you do in
here it is going to impact you
tremendously over the next
decade because it's already
impacted so much
over the last decade.
And so for me, that is
a very important thing.
But before I go into the
tactics that I want to bring
to everybody so you bring
home something tangible
I want to start with something
that I've been spending
a lot of time with and haven't
really expanded outside
of the content that
I've put on the internet.
So, on stage tonight I thought
a really interesting thing
to talk about would
be self-awareness.
If I can spend two to three
minutes with all of you
and make you understand that
self-awareness is probably
the single-most important thing
that you can spend time on
for your outcome,
for your future life
it would be so exciting to
me if hundreds or thousands
of people left here today
and started really realizing
who they actually were.
We're living in an era and
we have forever where people
have sold us on the optics
of what we should be,
where we should go.
Let me tell you
a story about myself.
It's really fun, I got
an email earlier today
or yesterday from a friend
of mine, Jay, that I went
to college with, who works
with Carolyn, who I went
to high school with.
Are you guys here,
can you guys stand up?
Can I find you?
Get up, there they are.
Can we clap it up for my homies?
(applause)
What's funny is both of them
know how bad of a student
I really was.
And what's really
interesting to me on that is
both of them also know,
that for some reason
at a very young age,
I was extremely self-aware.
I knew exactly who I was
and I was able to
bet on my strengths.
I think that, when
I think back to my life
and the story of my life, and
what I really wanna impose
on others to be
able to navigate through
is I was lucky enough to
have a mother who instilled
so much self esteem into my
body, I was able to navigate
through the universe of not
worrying about what everybody
else thought about me.
And what I've, really to be
very frank with you,
I've come to realize over
the last year or so
that I feel so much guilt,
just general guilt,
that I had it so good that
A, I came from nothing
which is a massive advantage.
Can the immigrants raise
their hands in this room?
Let's clap it up for
these people that have
a major advantage.
(applause)
We're lucky.
One thing immigrants realize
is how good it really is
so I had that, I had
nothing, and then I had a Mom
that did all the right things
for me and made me feel
so phenomenal and so
basically, I've come to realize
I've been asking myself
over the last year, like
why am I producing
so much content, like
what the fuck am
I really doing here?
I've got this $100 million
a year business to run
like why do I have fucking
DRock following me around
everywhere like, what
am I really doing here?
And I've come to realize
that I have so much guilt
inside of me, for having it
so good, that I want to use
my content, that if I can
play the role that my Mom
played for me, for
anybody in this room, then
then I've accomplished anything
that I could ever dream for
because, look, there's a
lot of people that are gonna
make money, but to me,
the most important thing is
how you make your money,
not how much you make.
And what I realized
Thanks Mom.
And what I realize,
what I realize is that
we live in a era now
where we can all document
and create content
around these narratives
and communicate in
a different world.
The thing that I'm
completely taken aback by
is the fact that this
is now the television
and the television
is now the radio.
And it's the late
forties and early fifties
and the people in this
room that understand that
and understand that
Snapchat and YouTube
and Facebook and Instagram
are ABC, NBC, ESPN and MTV.
(clapping)
You like that?
It's a good one, right?
But I'm not done yet,
you fucked me up.
All right.
(audience laughter)
And that the business and
the individuals in this room
that realize how to make
MASH or Seinfeld
or the best shows on
those platforms will win.
We're living through a major
shift where every person
in this room has
a binary decision.
Either you go on the defense
because of all of this
or you go on the offense.
Either you realize this is
the greatest opportunity
we've ever had, as
humans and entrepreneurs
or you're scared of all these
changes and you judge them
and you fear them.
And so for me, in this
huge shift of technology
and communication comes
the greatest opportunity ever.
Again, 'cause the theme
of the night for me
the fact that mainstream
media has been able to cast
such a cloud over this
ecosystem is fascinating to me.
I'll be very honest
with you, I'm not sad.
I'm not sad.
I'm pumped.
I am thrilled that so
many people think it's bad
'cause that's more
opportunity for me.
And so what I implore
you to do is spend
a hell of a lot less time
worried about other things
that will impact you
and spend a lot more
time to figure out
who you actually are.
What are you actually good at?
Are you actually in a
position to be successful?
What do you like doing because
the opportunities are endless.
The problem is we are scared
to do different things
because the
fundamental core reality is
we worry about what
other people think.
We worry about
getting judged if we fail.
One thing that I've
been very blessed with
is that I've traveled
the world quite a bit
for business and speaking
and one thing that a lot of
people may not understand is
that entrepreneurship
does not work
in a lot of other countries
because failure is
a scarlet letter.
Here, in the US, we're so
lucky that entrepreneurship
is met with when you fail,
you pick yourself
back up and you go.
And to me that is unbelievable
and we are blessed
to be in that ecosystem
and we need to take
full advantage of it.
- So look,
(audience applause)
I like the back.
Yes, back, step up.
This is real fuckin shit.
We are fuckin like, can
I ask you a question?
Do you understand that you're
only gonna live one time?
Everybody has a lack of
perspective and reality
of what's going on here.
We have so much opportunity.
You're in a fucking
convention center, in Boston,
listening to fucking Hamilton.
Wake the fuck up.
(audience applause)
Shit.
Seriously.
You have it so bad.
Perspective is so ridiculous.
The only thing I fear
besides the health and
well being of my family,
is regret.
The thing that I'm so scared of,
and one of the tactics,
if I can inspire
20 people to do this
that would be big,
fuck I'll take one.
If one person in here can
start spending more time
in a retirement home,
go, and donate your time,
your most valuable thing,
and go spend time with
70, 80, 90 year olds.
Do that for one day,
two days, a week or two,
and you will
understand very quickly
that the only
thing that is scary
is the things that
you didn't do, right?
It's those things.
And I sit here tonight,
and people are in their tactics,
they're in their business,
their startup,
they work in their companies,
and the thing that I fear
and the thing that
I'm passionate
about deploying tonight,
is really pushing
a little bit more
what I would
call practical risk.
Practical risk is something
that I've been
thinking a lot about.
A lot of people tell me
they can't take the chance
of going and doing
what they want to do.
Whether it's a different job,
whether that's, by the way,
I've gotten 100 emails
in the last six months
of people that needed the
courage to shut down their
startup and get a job
because they were worried
about the ramifications
of being made fun of
for not executing
on their business.
Whatever it is,
as you sit here tonight,
I want to deploy
and I want to start talking
about practical risk.
And what practical
risk means to me
is the thing that
I did not understand
until I started getting
thousands of emails
a year from individuals
is we're fucking fancy.
We're fucking fancy.
It's not that you can't,
it's that you're not
willing to give up dumb shit
for a better life.
You're not willing
to go backwards.
You're not willing to make
yourself dramatically happier,
to move out of your home
and downsize and go into
a different neighborhood.
You're not willing
to go backwards.
That to me is fascinating,
the fact that things, whether
home, car, watch, clothes,
going out,
is holding people back
from a substantially
happier life
is fascinating to me and
something that we
need to debate.
Because at the end of the day,
that one at bat is all we got.
And so if I can absolutely
push you one tangible item,
I see some people
have pads and pens,
and I'm fascinated by that.
Go, ready?
Go to a fucking,
F-U-C-K-I-N-G,
retirement home,
spend time, collect data,
realize regret is the worst,
and do something about it.
Got it?
Awesome,
let's clap it up for her.
(audience applause)
I really want to talk about
the phone and Facebook
and Instagram and Snapchat,
because it's a place I come from
and I wanna get a little
bit away from the heady shit
right now and get a little
bit back into practicality.
If you are not
producing content,
on the five to six major
social network platforms today,
you are creating an
enormous vulnerability
for whatever you'd
like to happen in life.
The person you want elected,
getting money
for your kid's charity,
selling shit.
Communication
has shifted forever,
and these platforms
really, really matter.
The problem is,
even at a conference like this,
where there is
so much marketing skill,
I am flabbergasted by the
lack of practitionership
in the actual creative ability
and paid media amplification
of creative to
make a business action.
I, for a lot of
you that don't know,
built my family's
liquor business
really on the back
of Google AdWords.
Google AdWords came out,
I bought the word
wine for $0.05 a clip,
and even though
I was doing direct mail
and doing local
television and billboards,
I get a lot of accolades
in this ecosystem
from building
my dad's liquor store
from a three to
a $60 million business.
But the truth is,
I stand here tonight
and admit to you not excitingly
that it should've
been $150 million.
Because if
I'd actually understood
how unbelievable
the arbitrage was,
on Google AdWords, I would've
spent a lot more money on it
and grew my business much more.
But, I was too patient.
I did well, not enough.
I did not go all-in,
and I built a nice business.
But in reality,
I left a lot on the floor.
Tonight, as we sit here
tonight, as we sit here tonight,
the number one arbitrage
in marketing in the world,
and I don't give
a shit if you do B2B.
How many people in B2B,
raise your hands?
Uh-huh, I know you fuckers.
How many people in B2C?
Uh-huh, so even better.
This is why I do this,
it allows me to go
in a certain direction.
B2B clients for me, at Vayner,
and the startups
that I'm involved with,
are doing even better than
B2C clients on social,
specifically Facebook,
because there's one
amazing thing about B2B.
We, and I'm in it
now with VaynerMedia,
we know the
name of the customer.
We know the businesses we want.
We even know the
decision maker we want.
The problem is, we suck.
We get real lazy, and we
send bulk fucking emails
on Linked-fucking-In.
Can we make a pledge tonight?
Actually you know what,
let's do this.
If you're willing
to pledge to no more
bulk email horse shit
spec email on LinkedIn,
stand up so I can
clap for you personally.
Make a pledge.
Let's wait, get up.
More, fuck this bulk email shit.
Don't sit back down
dude with the beard.
Get the fuck back up.
I see you, I'm talking to you,
yeah you.
There we go.
No, no, no, no, let's clap it
up for this pledge, no more.
(audience applause)
Enough.
Thank you.
Guys, best part is,
the shit doesn't work.
How many people here
have done email marketing
in their career,
raise your hands?
Are you looking for your seat?
Hey, looking for your seat?
(audience laughter)
Got it, okay.
How many people
here have done bulk email,
have done email
marketing in their careers,
I'm just curious?
In 1997, I had a 200,000
person email newsletter
for Wine Library and
WineLibrary.com
that had 91.3% open rates.
Not because I was a hero,
but because email marketing
hadn't existed yet.
The thing that
I'm most fascinated by
is that I know as a
marketer, and I'm a marketer,
as a marketer,
the number one thing,
the thing that I know more
than the sun
will come up tomorrow,
is that marketers
ruin everything.
(audience laughter)
It's what we do.
When I saw that
little fucking ghost,
I'm gonna fuck up that ghost.
I got you Snapchat.
I'm gonna ruin the shit
outta this platform.
(audience laughter)
You show me attention,
and I'll show you a
place that I wanna sell.
And that's how it gets changed.
And bulk email
in 2016 is insanity.
Nobody's opening that shit.
And what, just cause
you have an algorithm
that says, Hey Gary?
And by the way, I saw
10 of these emails today.
All the fuckers in this room
that have the Hey Gary thing
that's in a different font
than the rest of the email,
you suck.
(audience laughter)
Right?
I mean enough of that.
Jesus.
Fuck.
B2B, I'm gonna go tactical,
'cause I wanna leave with,
I wanna you know
lately I've been trying
to get even more
tactical in my keynotes,
'cause I love the
emails that I get where,
hey thank you so much,
it helped my business.
Here's the tactic.
I'm gonna give you the
best blueprint I have
for B2B selling right now.
And I really hope it
brings you some value.
And I'll go into, I'm
gonna go into it in detail,
I'm gonna get a little nerdy.
If you're in a B2B environment,
you have to run Facebook ads
and you have to do it now.
They cost about five to
six dollars CPM right now.
On average, the cost of
these CPMs will be $30,
36 months from now.
I'm saying this because I know
I'm gonna have
the video of this,
and in three years, you're
gonna see me share this clip
and I'm gonna tag it,
I told you so, motherfuckers.
(audience laughter)
It's gonna be $30 a CPM
because everybody's
gonna figure out how much
attention is really
on that platform.
So the supply and demand
curve is gonna change
just like wine now is a
six- seven dollar word.
Got it?
Okay, so now you're
gonna run Facebook ads
and first and foremost
you're not gonna outsource
it to somebody else.
You're not gonna find
little Susie that's 23
in the office and be like,
"You! You're young.
You know social media."
You're not gonna do that.
(audience laughter)
You're gonna actually
spend ten hours and read
and watch videos.
It's crazy.
You can learn anything.
So many people are like,
"Gary, but I don't know
"how to use the
Instagram product."
I'm like, "I get it.
You go to Google
"and you search it, Fuckface."
Okay?
(audience laughter)
That's what you do.
It's not super complicated.
It's crazy, anything
you don't know you can
search in two seconds.
Everybody is crippled
like they don't know.
It's fucking there.
You do that.
You become a practitioner.
You actually deploy the
Facebook ads yourself
so you have some
ability and knowledge
so somebody can't hose you.
You need to be the person
that knows it the best.
You then target,
there's a way to target,
employees of....
One more time,
B2B, raise your hands.
You guys know
who you're going after.
I want you to
target the employees
of that company one by one.
The employees.
Now you take a step back.
Now you know you're targeting
15, 17, 22 different businesses.
If you wanna get really crazy,
you target them
one by one and you make
videos or pictures
just for that company.
But if you want scale,
you can put them
all in a bucket.
And now you're gonna make
a video or a picture,
a billboard or print ad or
a television commercial,
and you're gonna make it,
and what you're gonna
do is you're gonna make
the creatives start with,
"Does your CFO know,
"Does your CTO know,
"Does your CIO know."
You know exactly
who in that organization
in that organization
is the person that
needs to see that content.
And you're gonna start
the video or your picture
with that statement
and I promise you,
for hundreds of dollars,
depending on the
size of your business,
sometimes for
thousands of dollars,
that person is gonna get
12 to 25 to 100 people
forwarding him
that piece of content
and that piece
of content will be the
gateway drug to
your sales team
to convert and close.
It works every time.
(audience applause)
That's it, right?
I could talk about...
You like that, right?
It's practical.
Black and white.
You got it?
I can talk about one
life and all that shit,
but that's fucking up
in the clouds, right?
THat's like who
gives a fuck, right?
Yeah.
I care.
Okay, that's one.
Good.
Next.
Two.
The single best
arbitrage in marketing,
and I wanna take a step back.
I wanna make
sure everybody understands.
I think the slide was up there,
we'll end the slide.
I day trade attention.
I am not a technologist.
I'm not digitalant this.
I'm not a fucking blogger.
What the fuck?
(audience laughter)
I'm somebody who is
obsessed with attention.
From when I was six
years old and instead of
standing behind the
lemonade stands I would
sit and watch cars
drive by and figure out
where to put the signs.
I was sick, you know.
To now.
I stand here and
actually say if you have
the money in
I would say HubSpot.
If I ran the marketing,
the number one thing
that I would do is run
a Super Bowl commercial.
I stand here today
as a marketer that
trades attention
and I believe that the
number one deal in
marketing today is actually
a Super Bowl commercial.
It's six million dollars
but the entire country,
whether they watch
it on YouTube or during
the game will know
exactly what you're up to.
Now most people fuck it
up because they try to
make some funny
video for 30 seconds
and then we forget,
but that is to me
the number one play.
The number two
play in the world is
Facebook video
because I believe that
not confined to 30 seconds
has the ability to build
enormous awareness.
VaynerMedia had a very
special thing happen
last week.
I don't know if any of
you guys caught this
but when the Cubs
won the World Series,
we ran...
(audience applause)
Who's from Chicago?
(cheers)
Finally, right?
Fuck.
108.
When the Cubs won
the World Series,
we ran an ad, an "ad"
after the World Series.
First it was Nike,
then it was us,
and we brought back
Harry Caray from
a classic 1984 commercial
and that went big
and everybody
said we were geniuses
and I got a lot
of emails that night
and it was super
awesome and I replied
to everyone saying,
"Wait until tomorrow."
What tomorrow was,
was the next day we
deployed a two minute plus
video where Harry Caray,
we took 30 years
of him calling games
and chopped it up
and had him over a
two minute video call
the final out of the Cubs
winning the World Series.
That video has
30 million plus views
at this point and
has drove a lot more
incremental growth and
awareness and B2B activity
for the brand than the
commercial did.
Though the commercial media,
like buying the commercial
and making sure
you all saw it cost multiples,
20, 30 times more
expensive than what
we deployed in
a Facebook environment.
This is what's happening.
My friends, I want you to
become historians of marketing.
I want you to also
understand what marketing is.
We have confusion
in the marketplace
of marketing and
branding versus sales.
We have a lot of
people in this room
that are digital
natives and they really
understand sales.
They understand optimization.
UI/UX.
They understand cost per click.
They understand how you
convert and change things
and things of that nature.
But what they
don't do is actually
brand and market.
And if your business is
growing you have to have
a healthy balance of marketing
and sales and branding.
My friends,
I did not buy these
sneakers because Nike
fucking cookied me
and sent me to some
fucking website
and converted me.
I bought it because of brand.
And there's a lot
of people here that are
mixing it up and
the reason Facebook
is so special is
it's the first platform
that I've seen
that does marketing
and brand and sales in one place
with underpriced attention.
If you grew up in
Google like I did,
there was no brand there.
We all had blue letters.
That brand was eliminated.
So, if I had one
plea for the collective
room tonight from
a marketing and branding
and business standpoint,
it is that we have to
understand the following.
And this is tough for
the digital landscape
but very easy for the
Madison Avenue landscape.
Creative is the variable.
Creative is the
variable of success.
The one thing that we all
trade on in this room,
no matter how and what you do,
whether you're B2B or B2C,
whether you sell
sneakers or wine or books
or your services,
no matter what,
we are all tied to attention.
We are all battling
for your attention,
but once you have my attention,
that creative is the variable.
If your video sucks
shit I can give you
9,000 ideas on
Facebook you will lose.
And that to me is
something that has to be
debated in this
ecosystem much more.
The other world I live in,
Madison Avenue,
where they believe
in commercials,
they're the other way.
They just think it's art.
If you understand and
start respecting both
art and science,
math and creative equally,
friction creating that diamond,
you'll be a successful marketer
over the next decade.
The problem is
we usually fall into
one camp or the other.
If you sit here
tonight please start
understanding
respecting and building
your skills around the one that
you don't actually do.
Because what's
happening is we have
unbelievably
overpriced attention.
The other thing
that's happening is
we have people that lack
self awareness to know
what they're good at and
what they're not good at.
And when you start
understanding those variables,
you start actually
making results happen.
I'm blown away by the
world that I live in today.
For a lot of you
that don't know,
I run a 750 person firm
called VaynerMedia.
I'm leaving here
right after this talk
going to London,
we just opened a London office.
What we do is we work with the
biggest brands in the world.
Under Armour and Chase
and Toyota and Pepsi.
And the amount of
money that is wasted,
just watch what I'm about
to show you and I think
we can all agree this is not a
14-year-old girl crowd.
Raise your hand if
you now when you watch
television fast forward
every single commercial
or watch Netflix or HBO GO,
when your favorite show airs,
you don't watch when it airs,
you watch it now on your time.
Raise your hands.
I just want everybody
to look around.
Keep 'em up.
Especially front row.
Look at this.
Let me just give
you the punchline.
Everybody.
- And how many people
here if they're still using
DVR or TiVo, fast forward
every single commercial
when given the option?
And so,
even if
something crazy like the remote
control falls off the bed,
every person here
grabs this any time that
there is a commercial.
Yet, $80 billion
is spent by the biggest
brands in the world
to make 30 second videos
of a Jeep going up a hill
or some guy grabbing a beer,
or some lady with a baby
using some oil, $80 billion.
It is completely not
practical, it is broken,
and it is the reason that
95% of the Fortune 500
biggest brands in the world
have declined in market share
over the last two years.
Here's what matters to
everybody in this room,
all that money,
all that money is coming
into our ecosystem.
Once they start calibrating
how bad it actually is,
when Coca-Cola and BMW
and the biggest, IBM,
start taking that money from
page 147 of Sports Illustrated,
and from a commercial
of Guiding Light,
and they take those dollars
and they put them into Facebook
and Instagram,
the price of our attention
is gonna go through the roof.
So I sit here today
and plea, and I plea,
that if you are not
activating your marketing
in that ecosystem, you are
gonna miss the golden era
of Facebook marketing
and you will regret it.
And people run around here,
there are people in this room,
that run around here with an
opinion on Facebook marketing,
and they've never
deployed a single ad on it.
There are people here that
run around and have opinions
on Instagram marketing
and have never deployed
a single penny on it, period.
Also, we sit here today
in early November 2016,
when the greatest
marketing arbitrage besides
Facebook advertising is
influencer marketing.
You may not like it.
You may not think it's
cool that people have
detox tea pictures
in their Instagram,
or that fucking waist thing
that freaks me the fuck out.
(audience laughter)
(chuckling) But it
doesn't take away the fact
that right now, even in
a B2B environment,
that if you took the
hours and map the people
that had 400 followers,
500 followers,
I'm gonna go back
into practical details,
you go into Instagram,
you go into search,
you start searching hashtags
for your business, SaaS,
right?
Whatever your industry's about,
and you start finding people
that post, you start
building a database
and then you email them
one by one with context.
We already made a fucking
pledge don't break it already.
(audience laughter)
And you ask them
to promote your shit.
And the price points are
incredibly under priced
for the amount
of attention you get
and the business
development opportunities.
Yet we continue not to do that.
Meanwhile, what's overpriced?
Twitter's overpriced.
It breaks my heart,
a lot of you guys know
that Twitter was
my coming out party.
It is absolutely the
platform that put me on.
It's not fun for me
to sit here and say
that it's overpriced,
but the problem is
Twitter has a fire hose problem.
There's so much,
and we don't populate it.
It's just like email
going from 90% to 30%,
and that is a problem,
and the ads are overpriced.
And that's just the ecosystem.
So unfortunately for them,
they're dealing
with what we're dealing with.
The other thing
that's overpriced is
all programmatic advertising,
banner ads are such a
mistake for businesses today
because there's nobody
here going to the right side
of dailydaily.org
and clicking a
fucking banner ad.
And so we sit here tonight
with an ungodly amount
of ridiculous marketing tactics,
and looming ahead of us,
is so much technology.
How many people here have
Alexa Voice in their house?
Alexa, raise your hand.
Stand up actually,
let's get the blood going.
Stand up, I need a context here.
Has Alexa in the home.
- Think Board!
- Yes I know,
you're on the screen.
You're pumped, right?
It's fucking awesome, right?
Get up here with me.
(audience cheering)
Very athletic, Jesus.
(laughing)
- You got a
Think Board in your office.
- Thank you man,
it's good to see you, good.
Just chill right here,
just chill.
- You've got
one of our products.
- I know, I'm aware.
Just sit, I think.
Yeah.
No, no, you can do
whatever the fuck you want.
You're fucking big boy,
I like it, do your thing.
- Thanks man.
- Hey man, how are you?
Jesus man, you look really
young, you look good.
All right.
(audience laughter)
I mean, that's good, but
this is way better, right?
Free advertising.
When you start
thinking about Alexa
and all these other
things, one of the things
that my career has been
completely predicated on
is the fact that I am
willing to take chances
on things that aren't mainstream
yet because I understand
that if I go after SocialCode,
and if I go after Vine
and if I go after MikMak,
and if I go after Yak,
if I go after all these
things that I only need one
of those seven to actually
hit, Snapchat, Instagram,
to win that bet.
We have enormous fear in
this room to, I have to wait or,
let's wait 'til it's big,
or what if I waste my time?
Awkward right?
Yeah, super awkward.
You could leave if you want
but you could chill too.
Got it.
- Will I waste my time on
these platforms, right?
Will I waste my time
on these platforms
if it doesn't become big?
And one of the other themes
that I really wanted to
leave here with tonight,
knowing the demo of this room,
is we have to have a
lot more risk tolerance
on new platforms.
If you're not playing,
back to details,
and I know you're taking notes.
If you're not playing with
Marco Polo and After School
and Houseparty, then you're
not there, potentially,
at the platforms that could
become the next things
at the top of our tongue.
How many people here,
let's be really honest.
Let's be really, really, really
honest with ourselves, Inbound.
Please raise your
hand if this is true.
How many people in this room,
and I want everybody
to look around,
said two and a half years
ago, three years ago,
maybe even a year ago,
that they would never be on
Snapchat, that was stupid,
and now have a Snapchat account?
Raise your hands.
Raise it high. Higher.
This is where all the action is.
This is the opportunity
in this room,
but we continue to downplay
the upside, 'cause we
fear the risk of
being on there and wasting time.
If you have not achieved what
you want to professionally,
or in life, time is the
number one thing you've got.
You need to deploy as much
of that as humanly possible.
That is the asset.
When you have not achieved
the things that you want
to happen in life, and
it is because of time
that you haven't wanted to
put in to these platforms
or worlds, that is
a massive mistake.
It's the one asset you have.
Not everybody in
this room has money.
It's true. You agree, right?
Are you gonna work
your fucking face off?
Thank you.
It's the one thing we have.
It's the one thing we
have, because everybody
wants to come up with excuses.
I've spent my
life reading excuses
on social media and my inbox.
I'm this, I wasn't born that
way, I wasn't born here,
this, I'm a female,
I'm an immigrant,
I'm a minority, I'm transgender.
Excuses.
Reality.
By the way, I truly believe
those are disadvantages.
I'm not naive to the
shortcomings of this country.
The problem is: nobody cares.
The market doesn't care.
We sit and we dwell,
and what do you think
we've been doing
for the last month,
and what we're gonna
do tomorrow morning?
We're gonna dwell and complain,
and that's utter defense,
instead of going on the offense.
We spend unbelievable
amounts of time dwelling
and wasting our
time on dumb shit.
People literally email me
and say, "You're so lucky,
"and I wish this
was happening to me,"
and then the third tweet, or
the third Instagram post is,
"Awesome Saturday. Stayed
home and watched entire season
"of fucking Game of Thrones".
We need to start understanding
how big this opportunity is,
because, for everybody in
this room, you will sit back
in 20, 30 years and regret
if you didn't execute
in this era, and, by the
way, I don't wanna hear
that this is for 20
and 30-year-olds.
40, 50,
60, 70.
It's an equal playing
field if you're willing
to be a practitioner and
understand the ecosystem
that I've been
speaking about tonight.
There's never
been a better time.
Look, it's very obvious.
These kind of characters:
there was no respect
for 20-year-olds in the
business world 20 years ago
when I came out, but now,
because of technology,
there's a lot of organizations
that absolutely respect
20 and 30-year-olds.
Also, what is happening is
I'm spending so much time
with 40 to 60-year-old
executives who are dwelling
and are upset, and tell me
dumb shit like, "But Gary,
"I didn't grow
up with this shit".
Neither did I, Alice.
(audience laughter)
I was 20 before
I even was on a computer.
I didn't grow up with this shit.
I figured it out,
and I sit there and see
completely capable operators
that have made it happen
for the last 20, 30
years being crippled by,
"I don't understand
how Snapchat works.
"It's so confusing".
We're just filled with excuses.
We are.
People are just
losing their hunger,
and then, by the way, let me
get really mad for two seconds
with my fancy, rich friends.
The thing that I'm
completely blown away by,
that I had no idea was
going on in capitalism
and meritocracy, is,
once you get rich,
you actually try to spend
your dollars to create laws
that allow you not to work and
still hold onto your money.
(audience applause)
A hundred percent, right?
I mean, I'm blown away by this.
You were benefited, because
in your twenties to 60,
for 40 years, you grinded
and out-executed somebody,
and you were able
to make lots of money,
but now that you're tired
and you're finished,
and you're older and don't
wanna put in the work,
you don't want
the next young buck
to come along and
eat your lunch.
That's not how capitalism works.
(audience applause)
It's true. It's just not.
And we have all these trends,
and we have the great
fortune of living in an era
where things have been really
good for a very long time,
and I walk around the world,
and I told my wife, Lizzy.
I'm like, "Lizzy, listen
to me. I don't care,
"clearly 'cause
I'm such a shit student,
"what the kids do
at school, but please.
"They can't be in programs
where we give away
"seventh place trophies".
(audience applause)
I have no idea who wins the
election tonight, but we need
to fucking ban seventh
place trophies in America.
(audience cheers)
And so we have all these
macro-situations going on,
and not to mention, for a
lot of people here under 30,
you haven't been in the game
during an economic downturn
'cause things have been very
cushy for the last seven
years where if you're 23 years
old and you have an idea,
you're company's miraculously
worth $4 million.
And so we're living in
a very intriguing time,
and I think that the
passion and the angst
and the energy that I bring
tonight are predicated
on a couple of
tried and true things.
Number one: If you're not
making long-term decisions,
you will be vulnerable.
The market's
changing very quickly,
and anybody who's looking
for short-term stuff,
gets short-term stuff and then
gets hurt in the long term.
Things like, Airbnb.
Guys, Airbnb shouldn't have been
invented by Brian and Joe.
Airbnb should have been
invented my by Marriott,
but Marriott is looking
short term and isn't
creating business models to
put themselves out of business.
Uber should have not
been created by Garrett.
They should have not been
created by Garrett and Travis.
They should have been
created by the guy or girl
that owned the most
medallions in New York City
or by Greyhound.
If you sit here tonight
and you're doing well,
you're in danger
because there's somebody
young and hungry that
has the internet,
which is a platform
that creates a zero cost
to get into the game
that's coming after
your shit.
So if you don't do what I do,
which is wake up
every single morning,
every single morning
and try to put yourself
out of business, somebody else
is going to do it for you.
It is much more fun,
my friends, to put
yourself out of
business then have
somebody else do it for you.
And so, please, if you're
cushy, who's cushy?
Raise your hand if
shit's going real well.
(audience laughter)
Jesus Christ.
Three people raised their hand.
I think you need to
shut down this fucking--
you doing good?
Awesome man.
What was that, I'm like
are you doing good,
you're like, yeah,
we're doing okay.
Yeah, right on.
Yeah, always.
So, you've gotta understand,
the only thing that's
interesting to me, and
the only thing I have--
I always say that basically
my career is predicated
much more similar
to Marino Rivera
than anything else
that I can think of.
If you're a baseball fan,
he was a very good
closer for the New York
Yankees, where, basically,
his entire career was
predicated on one pitch.
He had one pitch for 17 years,
and nobody could hit it.
And that's basically
my business career.
I've got one pitch,
which is the following,
I know what you're
gonna do before you
know you're gonna do it.
It's the thing that
I was gifted with.
Just like if you can sing,
just like you shoot.
I've always had the intuition.
I was made fun of, and
aggressively made fun of,
for launching a website
in 1996, because just like
people sit here and think
that Vine or Snapchat
is a fad, there's people
in this room
that remember where the
whole internet was a fad.
But I bet on it.
And I built a big business,
and then I was
made fun of because this
thing called YouTube
came out, and I took
a chance on that
cause I thought it was
gonna big and started
a wine show and
sat in front of a camera
and drank four bottles
of wine for 20 minutes.
And hundreds of thousands
of people watch it.
And then that worked.
And then Twitter worked.
And I invested in
Twitter and Facebook
and things of that
nature, but I had so many
losses along the way.
One thing that's never
talked about with my
genius career was that
I was on YouTube
super early,
but I left six months in
and started producing
Wine Library TV
exclusively on Viddler.
I was wrong.
(audience laughter)
One thing that's not talked
about is that I thought that
the biggest start-up in
the world in 2010
was gonna be Yobongo.
I was wrong.
(audience laughter)
And I continued to be
interested in being wrong
for the rest of my life,
because I am a
purebred entrepreneur.
Because I'm not
scared of trying things
and wasting my valuable
time because I want things,
and most of all, and
this is the most of all
of the whole thing,
I just genuinely
don't give a fuck about
what you think about me,
(audience applause)
balanced with, I really
care about what everybody
says about me.
(audience laughter)
And in that friction,
and I meant that.
You have to deploy real
ego and real humility
around this course,
because we live in that world.
But if I can inspire
anything in the time
that I was here today,
it's very simply this.
Please do me one favor.
I'm gonna wrap it
up with this, and this
matters so much to me.
Please, whatever it takes,
call your grandmother,
go to your great
grandfather's burial spot,
go back to the old country.
Go to a shelter.
Do something, do something
that re-calibrates your
perspective on what
is actually going on here.
We have never had it better.
My friends, I'm gonna
leave you with a very
interesting data point.
You guys like data?
Who likes data?
Great.
Let me give you
some fucking data,
more people in America
will die from a coconut
falling out of a tree and
hitting you on the head
and killing you, than terrorism.
(audience applause)
Yeah!
I see you tentative, like
is he fucking serious?
I'm dead fucking serious.
Kids seven to 11 watch
more Twitch, eSports
than all the four
major sports combined.
That's data.
We're living through a
totally different time.
Ten years ago, the
weirdest thing in the world
was your friend
dated people online.
Now every single person swipes
to the left and right 24/7.
And so the trends in our
society have changed.
And either, you're gonna
sit here and binary,
this is a black and white
conversation.
Either you're going to
leave here and understand
how fucking awesome it
is, and you're gonna
take full advantage of it
and be a winner.
Or, you're gonna sit and
dwell on all the negatives
of it, and be a losing player.
It's just the truth.
It's not complicated.
It's not fun for me to say.
I don't want you to lose.
I desperately want you to win,
but this is on you.
Nobody else is in control.
There are people who
deal with things like
the loss of their
children or real diseases.
We're sitting and
dwelling about not getting
enough likes on
fucking Instagram.
We're sitting and
dwelling about forces
that don't really
have impact on us.
It is time that this
collective room and our space
understands this is the
greatest golden era,
of not only business, but life.
And you really, and I mean
really, need to fucking grab it.
Thank you.
(audience applause)